من الواضح تمامًا أنه في السابع من أكتوبر، كان هناك
عدد كبير لا نعرف ما
هو العدد، لكن عددًا كبيرًا من
الإسرائيليين الذين قتلوا لم
يقتلوا على يد حماس، بل قتلوا على يد
جيش الدفاع الإسرائيلي، ولا أجد ذلك مفاجئًا
نظرًا لطبيعة  القتال الذي كان
يدور من الصعب التمييز
في تلك المواقف الآن
عقيدة هانيبال أمر مختلف تماما
الحجة هناك أو الإدعاء هناك
أن ما
تفعله إسرائيل أه هو أنه إذا كان يبدو
جنديا إسرائيليا حتى مواطنا إسرائيليا  سيتم
أسره من قبل حماس أو أي
جماعة إرهابية أخرى أه أه لاستخدام
اللغة الإسرائيلية لوصف تلك
الجماعات فيكون أه أه الجيش الإسرائيلي سيقتل
هؤلاء الإسرائيليين حتى لا يصبحوا
رهائن والمنطق هنا هو
أه الإسرائيليين  لديهم احترام كبير للحياة
البشرية لدرجة أنه إذا تم أسر الرهائن
سيكون من المستحيل تقريبًا على إسرائيل
ألا تدفع ثمنًا باهظًا
لاستعادة هؤلاء الرهائن لذا من الأفضل
قتلهم خلسةً أه أفضل
للجيش الإسرائيلي أن يقتلهم خلسةً أه
بدلاً من  اجعلهم رهائن
وهناك قدر كبير من الأدلة
على وجود عقيدة هانيبال هذه في
الممارسة داخل إسرائيل، وهي جريمة
قتل
أعتقد أنه يمكنك تسميتها
كذلك